do you think we need to worry about what
they're putting in our Electronics yeah
yeah I mean I'll give you one example I
bought this awesome vacuum and mop it
completely connects to a Chinese server
to uh to transmit and receive
information where you can turn the audio
on for it like when you plug it in it
says charging started charging stopped
like when you put it on and off I can
control that with my computer through a
Chinese Cloud Server there's no reason
that that vacuum and MOB should connect
to a Chinese cloud and at any point they
could change the way that functionality
works and take over my home network
[Music]
foreign